today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
so last night was the second night of
the democratic national convention we
had a live stream for the full two hours
there was the sort of formal
nomination process of joe biden with
each state casting their delegates
uh proportionally or 100 percent for
different candidates and
it was a significantly better night than
night one without question
there were fewer of these energy sucking
moments where after like an okay speech
they would cut to
low-energy smooth jazz or something like
that
it was better put together there were
actually some very interesting moments
headlined by
joe biden's wife dr jill biden who did
the last speech of the night who i
realized
in watching her she would be a better
president than donald trump forget about
joe biden for a moment
i was trying to think is there any issue
where if you said
david we need either donald trump or
jill biden
to figure out this issue is there any
issue where i would pick donald trump
and there really isn't
i mean even on coronavirus quite frankly
it's hard to imagine anyone doing a
worse job than
trump on the virus but as a doctor of
education
jill biden would just understand oh it's
a medical situation
oh well we need to let doctors take the
lead rather than than donald trump for
example but i'm heading
getting ahead of myself a little bit
here one of the best moments
was one of the best lines of the night
really was former secretary of state
john kerry referring to donald trump's
overseas trips as blooper reels take a
look at this
donald trump inherited a growing economy
and a more peaceful world
and like everything else he inherited he
bankrupted it
when this president goes overseas it
isn't a goodwill mission it's a blooper
reel
he breaks up with our allies and writes
love letters to dictators
america deserves a president who has
looked up to
not laughed at that actually made me
laugh in in the moment and john kerry
uh was was quite good at laying out the
importance of voting
for joe biden and to remove donald trump
in november bill clinton also spoke and
it was
fine there was debate about whether bill
clinton should speak or maybe instead it
should be al gore
who is sort of a direct testament to
what happens when not enough people vote
and you end up winning the popular vote
losing the electoral college and
changing the course of history maybe al
gore should have spoken instead maybe al
gore
should have spoken in addition to bill
clinton we heard from congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez in a much
anticipated speech it was very short
she formally nominated bernie sanders to
be the nominee there were some people
who said oh it's a snub
uh it was really a formality bernie was
set to receive delegates from some
states so
someone has to nominate him it was not a
snub
it was rather procedural and nbc news
took some heat because they misreported
what alexandria ocasio-cortez did and
they made a big deal out of it
i'm not going to since it really wasn't
a big deal and i don't want to play
into that but we did hear from aoc and
then yeah dr jill biden let's take a
look at just a little bit of her speech
and you'll see
this is the wrap up and you'll see joe
biden come out and embrace her if you're
watching and you'll hear him say just a
few words
if you are listening i know that if we
entrust this nation to joe
he will do for your family what he did
for ours bring us together
and make us whole carry us forward
in our time of need keep the promise of
america
for all of us
hey everyone i'm jill biden's husband
as you heard tonight excuse me you can
see why she's the love of my life
in the rock of our family she never
gives herself much credit
but the truth is she's the strongest
person i know she's a backbone like a
ramrod
she loves fiercely cares deeply nothing
stops her when she sets her mind into
getting something right
so yeah i mean it's all pretty cheesy
this this isn't the type of packaging
that appeals to me this isn't the type
of political event that appeals to me
but it doesn't matter i'm not the target
here and realistically neither are you
realistically anybody
who is watching the david pakman show on
youtube listens to political podcasts if
you listen to the podcast
you're not the target you you've already
decided right and so i think it's
important for us to keep that in mind
but i have to say
when you hear about and learn about
the tragedy of joe biden's life losing
his first wife and child
in a car accident and then you hear
about jill biden
becoming a mother to joe biden's two
sons while she was in graduate school
you just see the way the bidens relate
to each other it
is a reminder because of the stark
contrast that's in the white house right
now
about how absurd the trump
administration and trump as president is
on a personal level melania seems to
hate trump
some of trump's kids seem to hate him
trump
seems to think some of his kids are
idiots like
none of this is normal and obviously we
can separate
you know if their politics are great who
cares about their home lives
in this particular case with donald
trump it's all related
and it's all very very bad the same
delusions of grandeur and narcissism
that make his f a personal life and
family life a disaster
make his administration a disaster and
that was
you know i i didn't really need the
convention because the choices are so
crystal clear for me this time around
but i do think that this second night
particularly with dr jill biden and some
of the backstory on joe biden's life
i do think it actually was far better
put together
than night number one so tonight we're
going to be hearing from
senator elizabeth warren which i'm very
much looking forward to again
as someone who competed against joe
biden in the democratic primary this
year
we heard from by uh bernie on monday
night
making the case that if you supported
bernie in 2016 if you supported bernie
in 2020
here is why it is so important to vote
for joe biden in november
i'm interested to see how elizabeth
warren
puts together a sort of similar argument
i'm not as much
looking forward to hearing from nancy
pelosi and hillary clinton tonight
although i think it will be interesting
to see what approach they take
and whether they play to the left or
they play to the middle or what they do
we're going to hear from former
congresswoman grab gabby giffords who
is a tragically was a victim of gun
violence years ago
and also headlining tonight we will hear
from vice presidential candidate
kamala harris and we're also going to
hear from former president barack obama
all leading up to the final night
tomorrow
when we will hear from the nominee
himself
joe biden and it's much anticipated
for different reasons by different
people the right is anticipating joe
biden's speech
with the idea that he's going to be
barely coherent and
unable to put together anything sensible
or sensical
um whereas i'm interested in seeing
what is the approach in order to bring
people in
in other words centrists center left
disaffected republicans progressive
leftists former bernie people
so on and so forth so i will see you
tonight
at 8 45 pm eastern time on youtube
twitch
and or facebook your preference for the
start of night 3
and we will be back of course tomorrow
with analysis and preparation for the
final night of the democratic national
convention
and then we have to get ready for the
republican national convention happening
next week
okay now this is sort of funny but some
people are furious why because people
are furious about everything these days
bomb throwing right-wing radio host rush
limbaugh quoted me yesterday he actually
read one of my tweets
and it was one of the tweets i sent
during
the stream of the first night of the
democratic national convention
at the time i didn't think it was going
particularly well because it wasn't
so i'm going to play the clip of rush
for you then i will talk about the
reaction
from some on the left to this and just
how completely misguided
and and missing the boat some people are
about this let's look at russia's clip
first
david pakman political tv
radio show host tweeted someone please
talk me off the ledge
i want to win the first 22 minutes of
this convention i'm
scared can somebody tell me how great
this is or something can somebody make
me feel better
didn't start well okay so the exact
tweet that he read he added a paraphrase
at the end which is make me feel better
i didn't actually tweet that
i tweeted 22 minutes into night one
quote
someone please talk me off the ledge i
want to win
and the first 22 minutes of this dnc i'm
scared
can someone tell me how great this is or
something now
later on it improved and i said it did
particularly with michelle obama's
speech at the end of the night and night
two was
significantly better than night one
overall but here's what i want to talk
about with you
um i mentioned earlier and yesterday
that some people on the left were mad at
me they were even furious at me
i even had a few cancellations for lack
of a better term
because i was criticizing the first part
of night one of the dnc
and there were people on the left
reacting
with you know this feeling of how does
david have the audacity to criticize
what the dnc is doing
that i'm the problem because i'm
pointing out that i don't like some of
this stuff
and i'm being mean and i'm not being
supportive enough of removing donald
trump or being a team player or whatever
that is exactly the bs
garbage tone policing gatekeeping
nonsense that leads us to losing and
some people said david
when you tweeted that you literally
created fodder for the right
in the sense that rush limbaugh then
read your tweet
but the dnc was not going well at that
point in time i didn't like what i saw
the right was going to say it was
terrible no matter what
so it wouldn't make a difference in that
sense because the right is going to come
out and say this
is terrible and what an embarrassment
and blah blah blah
i said what i believe to be going on and
you know what later on it improved and i
said so
i'm not saying it improved because of
what i said
but who gains anything from me lying to
you
and saying wow this is really great this
is
this is going so well and so when i see
these comments
oh you ended up supporting republican
talking points
by tweeting that no i reacted genuinely
that's the promise
that's the premise and the promise of
this program my commitment here
is not always to say what you think it's
not
to be on board with whatever is the
orthodoxy of the democratic party i'm
not even a democrat remember
the reason people watch the live streams
and the content
is to get my honest and immediate
reactions to what's going on
what do we gain if i do political
theater where i say you know this is
crap
but it would look bad if i say that so
i'm going to pretend that this is great
and lie to my audience like is that
actually what people are suggesting i
should do
because rush limbaugh read one of my
tweets
the fact that limbaugh read a tweet
is no more evidence of anything than the
fact that
hitler breathing oxygen says anything
about
oxygen more broadly if you understand
the point
that i'm making alluding to an ad
hominem fallacy here and so
we really gain nothing by scolding
people
who are making what are honest critiques
and we actually i would make the case
lose a lot
when we do this tone policing and
attempting to regulate
what counts as acceptable commentary and
i was
out of line apparently with what is
really a pretty milk toast tweet guys i
mean in the end
this tweet is nothing's hinging on this
tweet so
i think it's interesting i don't know
exactly how my tweet
made it to rush limbaugh now years ago
rush limbaugh did a whole
segment where he refers to this program
and a segment we did multiple times
without calling it by name
and so we know that somehow over time
clips have gotten to rush limbaugh i
don't know how this got to him quite
frankly but somehow it did
um but uh listen if if you want a show
that will just always praise what the
democratic party is doing
i'm sure those shows exist it's just not
this one okay
and so i'm not apologizing and i will
continue to call it like it is
august 23rd is the 15th anniversary of
the david pakman show
we will be doing a huge membership
special if you want to be notified about
it
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com uh
august 23rd email will go out telling
you how to take advantage
of what we hope will be the biggest
single day surge in memberships in david
pakman show history
and of course remember that you can get
the podcast on
any app you like spotify stitcher google
play
itunes pandora if that is your gig
get the daily audio podcast take it with
you
every single day the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com what if you could
read
10 books in just one sitting that's
exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are mary
nygard
and lucas germain mary and lucas thank
you for your support and
also a huge thank you to david stemper
david's today's longtime
sustaining member of the day has been a
member almost five years
grab yourself a membership at
joinedpakman.com there is an
extra show every day for our members
called the bonus show
award-winning of course awards we give
out but still they are awards
a bonus show every single day uh sign up
at joinpakman.com
okay breaking news right it sounds like
our activism worked
donald trump's postmaster general louis
de joy
will be suspending reforms and
initiatives
for the post office until after the
november election
according to a draft statement that
reuters
is reporting on great news right dejoy
says i'm suspending these initiatives
until after the election
this is being done to avoid even the
appearance of
impacting election related mail we won
right guys
except not so fast not so fast at all
this is not what it seems this
announcement is
the post office will not be changing
retail hours
existing mail collection boxes will
remain where they are
no more mail processing facilities will
be closed
but notice that absent is the answer to
the question
what happens to what you've already done
so there's a couple of different things
here that we have to talk about first of
all
at some surface level i mean okay good
right i don't wanna
i don't wanna dismiss this as nothing
the activism the sounding the alarm
the pulling to joy in uh to answer
questions before
lawmakers it led to an announcement that
more isn't going to be done that's good
i guess and and we should recognize that
but the reality is that the damage may
have already been done the changes that
they've made already
have been done in disproportionately
blue areas to restrict delivery of mail
to create
pileups and his statement says nothing
about we're also going to undo all of
the things we've done in the last three
weeks
it says they will be suspending future
changes
until after the election so i don't know
about you
but i'm not particularly reassured by
this he may have already done what
needed to be done
in the blue voting areas and this could
be an announcement in fact
to give a false sense of security so
just remember these people are not our
friends
we have no reason to trust them he has
done a huge amount of damage
some sorting machines have been
dismantled some collection boxes have
been closed
so the idea that this is a victory of
accountability
where we now don't have to worry about
this we fixed it we won guys now
everything's fine with the mail
for the purposes of the upcoming
election it ignores reality and
i don't think i'm being too cynical by
saying this although
if you think i am let me know the other
part of this that
really needs to be restated is that this
announcement
is not a license to say i now
don't need to worry and i'll just send
my absentee ballot
the day before the election and be
confident that it's going to be counted
again
they are not undoing the damage that
they have already done
as far as we can tell in as far as has
been stated so far
so if it were me and i am in this
position in the sense that
i'm voting absentee and i will have to
make a decision about
how and when i send in my ballot i would
return the ballot as soon as possible if
you're mailing it
if you have the ability to drive it to a
ballot box
i would do that as well and that's
actually my plan
here in massachusetts i will be bringing
my ballot
to city hall if i ever get it i told the
story yesterday of how
i actually still have not received my
ballot for the primary
which is september 1. i requested it at
this point something like 13 14 days ago
and i would encourage other people to
just make sure you have a plan that
makes sense
based on what's happening in your state
based on where you can drop off ballots
in your state
and don't make your plan on the basis of
a false sense of security from this
announcement that's the most important
message i think they have done a bunch
of stuff
and now they're trying to get everybody
to forget about this by saying hey you
know what
to avoid the appearance of of maybe
affecting election mail
we're not going to be making any more
changes
well they've already done a bunch of
stuff we just don't know
the full extent of it we don't know the
full extent of what what's been taken
offline
so we we just can't chance it is the
point and at the end of the show today
during the voicemail segment i am going
to be talking
a little more about the ballot drop-off
situation
and how it really varies from state to
state and of course
that also makes this complicated we're a
country of 50 states
plus dc plus some territories and we
have
50 different election systems
essentially
with dramatically different rules in
each state in terms of how primaries and
elections are done where ballots can be
dropped off
and so much more so i'm going to address
that a little bit more later in the
program
there's been a super interesting turn of
events in the last
48 hours or so where donald trump has
called fox news
fake news at a recent event and after
day one of the dnc
multiple fox news anchors actually
heaped praise upon michelle obama for
her speech which was a good speech
so let's not read into this more than
what it is but i do think there's an
interesting discussion here here's
donald trump in wisconsin this week
calling fox news fake news
but we're doing great coming back we're
coming back and our numbers are better
than almost
all countries i will tell you that
despite what you hear look at all of
them up there
scott look at all of that fake news it's
unbelievable
unfortunately fox has become fake news
too i don't know what happens to these
people
right do you agree and then continuing
the reversals
behavior that is opposite what we would
expect what we've come to expect
on monday night check out dana perino
chris wallace people liked michelle
obama's speech on fox news
over the course of the night the first
virtual convention of our history
i think they would say that michelle
obama stuck the landing chris wallace
your thoughts
well i agree with dana you know it's
interesting michelle obama
as she said doesn't like politics and uh
she said that this speech was her main
contribution
uh to the biden campaign it was a heck
of a contribution
she really flayed uh sliced and diced
donald trump
talking about the chaos and confusion
and lack of empathy especially
coming from this president and from this
white house spoke more about
the deficits of donald trump than the
pluses of joe biden but
did talk about especially not so much
policies but especially
his empathy what he's been through and
his care for average american she said
we have to vote
so what do we make of this is this some
major reversal where fox news is no
longer right wing
and uh no longer supporting trump and
fox news now supports democrats
no no no no not not even in the
slightest
uh it's a very instructive example
to understand a little bit about how
corporate media works in the united
states
fox news offers theatrics and hyperbole
from a right-wing perspective for profit
and the for-profit part
is a big piece of the analysis so think
back to early
in the 2016 republican primary which
started in 2015 really
the role of fox news was we cover trump
being kooky but we oppose him because
we're a serious right wing network and
we support people like you know whoever
the buttoned up right winger was at the
time was it jeb or was it
you know ted cruz or whatever doesn't
matter trump then wins the primary
then fox news falls in line and gets
behind donald trump because they're not
going to get behind hillary clinton
hillary's bad
obama's bad they get behind trump and it
is a
business decision fundamentally and a
decision about if trump is president i
mean he's the nominee if he's president
we want access to trump
trump becomes president and is
completely outrageous as president
so fox news actually sort of does a dr
jekyll and mr hyde
sort of thing the opinion people remain
solidly behind trump carrying water for
him you know sean hannity
janine pirro laura ingram tucker carlson
mostly
uh the fox and friends people who i know
that's supposedly a news show come on
guys that's an opinion show
but they do want to gin up controversy
and kind of play all sides so when shep
smith still worked at the network
he would sometimes call out trump for
his obvious lies or
chris wallace will confront trump during
interviews or whatever the case may be
okay now we find ourselves in a
situation where it's unclear if donald
trump is going to win so
fox is running parallel narratives again
for profit this is what explains the
entire
sort of status quo at fox news hannity
and the opinion people
are mostly still behind trump if trump
wins
trump will still be there for them and
they'll be there for trump if donald
trump is reelected
if trump loses foxes laying out a little
bit of the groundwork they're laying a
little pipe so to speak to say
we're objective we criticized trump
or praised democrats like michelle
obama's speech when it made sense
and the point is to be positioned after
november for any eventuality to maintain
access to people in positions of power
period now you might be wondering
does do fox executives pull chris
wallace aside and go listen chris
we need you to praise michelle obama and
really be tough on trump
so that we can do this plan no that's
not the way it works it's much the same
way as you know
rt anchors will often say
i actually haven't seen rt in years but
years ago i don't even know if it's
still on tv in the us honestly but
but years ago rt anchors would say i've
never been
told what to say on the air in terms of
russian narratives or whatever no that's
not the way it works right
you are selected because you have been
hired
in a role right you you you uh are
choosing the people
that on their own will play the roles
that you are trying to fill and it's
much the same
thing on fox news so i don't believe
it's calculated in that chris wallace
needs to be told what to do
chris wallace just needs to be put in
positions to do what chris wallace does
and that's how they build the narrative
so
the bottom line is money that's really
it the murdoch family isn't stupid
the big goal is be in line with
conservative governments
be friendly with right-wing governments
around the world
if they can help the right retain its
power
then they will swing some support to
whoever
uh is likely to win and that's the
strategy
if it looks like the right will lose
power
then they will put a little bit of
support just enough
behind whoever is likely to win so that
when that person wins be it joe biden or
were it hillary clinton in in 2016 they
can
maintain access and they can kind of
create a responsibility from the winner
to still treat fox news seriously
because that's how fox news continues to
sort of
replicate itself and perpetuate itself
this is business 101
you might notice there's no journalism
analysis here
this is not a communications uh analysis
where you would understand you know in a
in a theoretical academic communication
class
about anything related to journalism or
media this is business
this is what you would learn in business
school and if you try to evaluate this
as journalism
the commentary makes no sense if you see
this through the lens of business
then it makes perfect sense and that's
exactly what this is
for fox news don't be tricked into
thinking that it's anything else
we'll have more coverage of this on the
show's instagram
david pakman show on instagram and while
you're there you can follow me on
instagram
at david.pacman as well
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to have back on the program
after
i don't know how many years really it
feels like a long time ago
holyoke massachusetts mayor alex morse
who now also is candidate for congress
in massachusetts first congressional
district my old district i don't live
there
anymore but it was it was my district
for a while alex it's great to have you
on
yeah thanks so much for having me back
david i think it's been about nine years
i think it has been that long yeah at
the time we were both much younger last
time
yeah but we look the same we look
exactly the same that's the good news
yeah at least for now five more years
will be a little different
anyway if trump wins for sure um okay
so you're mayor of holyoke and you're
running
this democratic primary campaign the
primaries on september 1st
um people should already have requested
and hopefully have in hand
ballots if they're voting absentee i
know people that have already
sent them back in so this this is all
sort of happening right now
talk a little bit about your approach
here
as someone who is up against the
longtime
incumbent in richard neal someone that
is seen by some as part of the
establishment someone that is seen by
others as someone who
maybe is doing a good enough job where
where they would not want to see him
replace
what's your approach here yeah so we
launched this campaign
about 13 months ago we knew it would
take a great deal of work to build the
kind of movement across western mass
this is a district of 87
cities and towns from the hilltown so
the berkshires rural parts of this
district down to
urban communities like springfield and
holyoke and so you know we have a member
of congress now that just
is unable to grasp the urgency of the
moment on every issue
he's absent he's unaccountable and he's
been there for over 30 years
and it's a different time than it was in
the late 1980s
and it requires a different a different
sort of lens of which we view policy and
just different solutions to the
challenges that we now have
and so our goal has always been to build
a grassroots campaign we always knew we
would get outspent
and outraised and our goal was to make
sure that we have the people power
the grassroots campaign and the
resources that we need to defeat
this congressman on september 1st and
you know 12 months later
and 13 days out from the election we are
well on our way
to doing that and it's a testament to
the people that have
just felt forgotten about and left
behind by the federal government
in in recent years so we'll talk you've
had some
big boosts in fundraising over the last
seven days and we'll talk about the
genesis of all of that in a bit
but as you point out this is a district
that includes
springfield massachusetts a city that
has
a very very different circumstances and
problems than places like
i think huntington is also part of the
district or you know another
very rural small town with one stoplight
if anything
so i mean the what what huntington needs
and what springfield needs are two very
very different things
how do you assess working on both
yeah and so just yesterday we announced
the support of over 30
rural elected officials and community
leaders
who feel very much forgotten about and
left behind that
the perception now is not only do we
have a member of congress that hasn't
had a town hall in the district in over
three years
but people want a member of congress
that shows up in particular
in the hilltowns and in the rural parts
of the district and whether you live in
holyoke or springfield or huntington
or chester or north adams people are
feeling again
not represented by this current occupant
of of this seat and you would never know
we have one of the most powerful members
of congress
representing us when you look at
outcomes the fact that dozens of cities
and towns still are without
basic access to broadband internet that
we have public schools closing in the
hilltowns that can't afford the cost of
municipal health insurance
we have hospitals closing one in north
adams hundreds of inpatient psychiatric
beds closing here
in in holyoke and hampden county and
springfield still the asthma capital
of our entire country and i've made a
commitment to having a rural desk
making sure that we have a staff and a
presence in the hilltowns and in the
rural parts of this district
to make sure that everybody that lives
here in western and central mass knows
that they have an ally in washington
so most of my audience obviously doesn't
live in the massachusetts first
congressional district but they
they live in the united states and so if
you were to become a member of congress
you would be one of 435 votes on a whole
bunch of things that would affect people
who are in florida or los angeles or
or wherever so i'd like to talk a little
bit about your
your approach to some of the big issues
right now that can sometimes be dividing
lines when we think about who should be
representing us so like for example
big picture on taxation we had a tax
reform bill in 2017
from the current administration and
republicans there's
a view that taxes should be much higher
on some people
or lower on others or whatever the case
may be to pick an
issue that is relatable to everybody
what's your perspective on what congress
should be doing on taxes
yeah and i would i'll get to taxes in a
moment but this is a race and i want
listeners to know that has national
implications because
i'm challenging the chairman of the
house ways and means committee
and i'm not contesting the fact that
congressman neil has power he has power
as the chair of the ways and means
committee
but he's not using his power number one
to hold this president accountable
he dragged his feet for months to even
request the president's tax returns
refused to seize the new york state
returns that lawmakers there
worked for years to make available he
was one of the last congressional
democrats to embrace and support an
impeachment inquiry
into this president and along with
elliot engel is the only other
democratic chair in leadership
that hasn't had a single oversight
hearing on any component of the trump
administration
since the democrats took back the house
and so instead of using his power for
oversight
he's using his power to again be
complicit
in many of the priorities of the trump
administration he is an ardent opponent
of medicare for all
even as millions of americans are losing
their job and their employer-based
health insurance
he's the only member of congress here in
massachusetts that refuses to sign
on to the green new deal he even in the
middle of this pandemic has come out
against
a monthly recurring payment of two
thousand dollars to the most vulnerable
americans
that are being left behind he has
opposed primo legend paul's paycheck
guarantee act
and right now he is literally the number
one recipient of corporate money in the
entire house of representatives
more than any democrat and even more
than every republican and
in regards to taxation in particular yes
this is a congress a democrat
that is openly opposed to a wealth tax
he has supported the carried interest
loophole
i mean the ways and means committee in
particular is the committee that should
be doing oversight hearings
on the 2017 tax package he has done
nothing to address it
he has done nothing to raise the
corporate tax rate instead he's using
his power
to mitigate the possibility politically
of achieving a wealth tax and if we
defeat congress mcneal on september 1st
it's all but assured that there will be
a member of the progressive caucus that
becomes chair of the ways and means
committee
that supports medicare for all that
supports a green new deal that supports
a wealth tax and a higher corporate tax
rate that we can actually invest in
domestic priorities
that would make a difference in people's
lives here in western mass okay but to
get back to my question
a little bit um on as let's go even more
detailed then
so you mentioned a wealth tax you
mentioned a recurring payment during
during the pandemic our current top
marginal tax rate right now is in the
mid 30s
where do you think the top marginal tax
rate should be do you want to see
a higher bracket at 45 50 70
as some other potential future
colleagues of yours have suggested where
would you put that
yeah i'm much more in line with
elizabeth warren's concept
of a wealth tax that the wealthiest one
percent um you know be it a penny or two
on every dollar over a certain amount of
money and it is
criminal in this country that working
families and middle class families are
paying essentially more in
taxes to the federal government than you
know
folks at facebook and google and amazon
i mean
as a percentage of income you mean as a
percentage of income absolutely
and i think we also need to take a
closer look at modern monetary theory
i mean these archaic views of the
deficit and government spending
i mean we have the resources we need to
fight climate change to provide health
care as a fundamental human right to
provide
free public college but when you have
democrats like congressman neil
peddling right-wing talking points about
the deficit and our inability to make
these investments
at the very time 60 of our federal
budget goes to the pentagon
i mean we need members of congress not
just not just any democrat but democrats
that actually understand this
um to go to washington and just change
the conversation in regards to these
issues
on pentagon funding how specifically
would you propose
reducing it i mean would you close bases
in places like germany for example
yeah i think i think first and foremost
we need to evaluate the necessity of
having
dozens of military bases around the
world and i think we need to have a
foreign policy that isn't
isn't eager to to sort of get itself
involved in unnecessary coups of
democratically elected leaders
around the world um and when we think
again 60 of our federal budget goes to
war and defense
um i think is completely unacceptable
and i think there was some good effort
among the democrats to reduce it by 10
but i think
i mean that's the floor and i think we
need to continue going further than that
so this race the massachusetts first
congressional district has been not only
does it have national implications as
you point out
but it's also become very interesting to
all sorts of different folks around the
country over the last 10 days
because of a controversy that started
when the massachusetts college democrats
put out a letter
sort of generally alleging but without
naming any individuals or putting names
to it
um alleged inappropriate actions by you
when it comes to personal relationships
when you were teaching a course at the
university of massachusetts
and in your role there working with with
college democrats at umass
and this has exploded to the point where
you know glenn greenwald has been
tweeting about it
um ryan gray you know all sorts of
people i follow unfit you know i've
known you for a decade and people that
had i had never mentioned you before
tweeting about it this is exploded now
um you've been able to raise a lot of
money as a result
and i want to talk about whether you
think maybe it is backfired to some
degree but
first of all the sort of core of it is
do you accept that you have acted
inappropriately
at any point in any way or do you reject
the allegations on principle
i reject the allegations on principle i
mean evidence has now come to light
that essentially proves that this was a
coordinated political attack
on behalf of supporters of the
congressman that were in fact trying to
curry favor with one of the most
powerful incumbents
in washington i mean this was a story
that was shopped around to mainstream
media
for months and every journalist rejected
it
because it was vague it was non-specific
no one would go on record
i mean this was essentially a blog post
that was printed in a student newspaper
that was unamplified to the local media
by by media here across massachusetts
and by national media outlets
and now thanks to the investigative
reporting of the intercept
and the journalists there we have now i
mean pretty much by the day
have learned more and more behind the
political motivations of this
that goes to the height of the
massachusetts democratic party
itself and i have been very clear and
unapologetic about my identity as a
young
single gay person and and not having to
apologize for having relationships
consensual relationships with other
adult men in my life
and do you you say that there are
individuals
associated with and looking to curry
favor with your opponent but at this
point do you allege that your opponent
either knew that this was being done or
was involved in any way
i mean i think it is certainly
suspicious and i will let the people of
the district come to their own
conclusions but i think people are
certainly seeing this for what it is
that three weeks before the most
competitive election that this member of
congress has ever seen
this suddenly happens i mean it is no
accident it is no coincidence
and so people are seeing through it and
then the language that has been used in
response
i mean age-old homophobic tropes yes
that have been used
thrive gay men who are all too familiar
with the over policing of our personal
lives and our sex lives
i mean this the response to this hasn't
just been an attack on me as a candidate
and as a person
and it has had a great impact but it's
been an attack on all of us in our
entire community and it certainly
invigorated our supporters invigorated
the people here in the district
and has invigorated and inspired people
to get off the sidelines into this race
that
that weren't involved before let's pause
our conversation there with holyoke
massachusetts mayor alex
morse who is of course a candidate for
congress in the massachusetts first
congressional district democratic
primary
the full conversation with him will be
up on our youtube channel
youtube.com the david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
donald trump has now floated the idea of
invalidating and redoing the november
presidential election
at some point in the future trump did
some kind of event commemorating women's
right to vote it was really bad from the
get-go
and here is donald trump saying we might
have to redo the election because of all
of the voting that will be done by mail
we have to have honest voting that's
what this
is all about here it's honest voting you
can't take
millions of ballots send them
haphazardly all over the country or
all over a state and expect to
come out properly and if you look at the
last 10 elections where they did this
universal
and by the way absentee is great it's
been working for a long time like in
florida absentee you request
and it comes in and then you send it
back absentee is great
but universal is going to be a disaster
the likes of which our country
has never seen it'll end up being a
rigged election or they will never come
out with an outcome
they'll have to do it again and nobody
wants that and i don't want that
so trump's first salvo was that it might
take
days to know the results now people
weren't really worried about that
it would be fine for it to take a few
days as long as we get the right results
so trump had to scale it up he had to go
hyperbolic and then trump went to saying
you know it could take days weeks or
even months to know the results of the
november election
that just wasn't believable so more
recently trump's been going
full fake panic by saying it could take
years to know the results and now he's
added this cherry on top
the craziest which is we might have to
throw out the election results
altogether
and redo the entire election now what's
funny is when he says that
he never says what would be different
when we redo it like is is the
implication
we would have to redo the election but
without any voting by mail like what
what how would the next how would we
doing it fix the problem
unless we do the election in a different
way doesn't really matter this is all
crazy
now donald trump also had announced on
monday night
this is so crazy on the way back from
his rally in wisconsin
trump announced on monday that yesterday
he would be making
a big announcement about pardoning
someone and he said it's not going to be
snowed in it's not going to be
i don't remember whoever else and he
made this announcement yesterday during
this same event commemorating women's
right to vote
donald trump announced that he would be
pardoning
susan b anthony who died in 1906
the announcement which trump had
promoted as a major announcement
it was met with literal laughter in the
room you have to see this video you have
to listen to this
you're going to hear loud laughter when
trump says i'm going to pardon susan b
anthony
people think it's a joke and then they
realize
oh my god trump is serious and they
start to clap
sort of like politely out of pity i i've
never seen anything like this
incredible document that i'm signing and
i wanted to just add something because
this was
brought up a week ago and i was so
surprised that it was never done before
because later today i will be signing a
full and complete pardon
for susan b anthony she was never
pardoned
did you know that she was never pardoned
what took so long the women behind trump
literally think it's a joke that trump
is telling that it's not real
they thought this was going to resonate
somehow the white house did
why else would they do this and then a
moment
that is indistinguishable from parody
donald trump is asked if he supports the
protesters in belarus
and trump i guess heard protesters and
terrorists
and it just gets really weird it's like
a weird freudian slip combined with
trump going off the rails and bashing
the protesters
in portland oregon when asked about
belarus take a look at this
do i support protesters and terrorists
oh i thought he said protesters and
terrorists
for moscow regarding potential military
yeah
you have to understand me i like seeing
democracy
democracy is a very important word it
doesn't seem like it's
too much democracy there in belarus
but we are speaking to lots of people
and we'll be speaking at the appropriate
time to russia
and we'll be speaking to other people
that are involved but it's certainly a
very big
march and it seems to be a very peaceful
march other than the
other unlike some of the so-called
peaceful protests that we have where
they burn down stores
okay peaceful protest those are not
peaceful those are anarchists
going over to portland and other places
these are anarchists agitators these are
very bad people
just a complete and total inability to
discuss
policy in anything approaching
substantive a substantive way and then
lastly trump is asked about michelle
obama's dnc speech from monday which
even fox news said was pretty good
and he says she was dead wrong we have
way more coronavirus deaths than she
said we have
trump's trump's fact check if you can
imagine maybe
because the speech was recorded a few
days earlier trump's fact check is
her speech was bad because under my
administration we've actually had
way more coronavirus deaths than
michelle obama claims
yeah no she was over her head and
frankly she should have made the speech
live which she didn't do she taped it
and it was not only taped it was taped a
long time ago because she had the wrong
deaths
she didn't even mention the vice
presidential candidate
uh in the speech and you know she gets
these spawning reviews if you gave a
real review it wouldn't be so funny
owning the libs by saying no no no
michelle was wrong
more people have died of coronavirus now
she recorded it a couple of days ago
and then absolute last thing on this
trump again
talks about how the obama administration
got bad reviews
on swine flu notice if you're watching
this video
the woman over trump's left shoulder she
looks physically ill during this
take a look well they got very bad
reviews if you look at the gallup
poll gallopol did a review of them now
you have to understand that was a far
lesser uh vicious disease
it was not the same in the same ballpark
but yeah i know it's also a much lesser
disease
but they got very bad reviews gallup
gave very bad reviews and by the way
gallup
at that same time gave us very very good
reviews
for the job we've done so if you take a
look at the gallup poll
from a couple of months ago we got very
good reviews and they got very bad
reviews they were they were
i mean the reviews they got for the
handling of
swine flu or h1n1 which biden calls
n1 h1 and i don't even correct him on
that
i don't even correct him i said no
that's a mistake you can make
but that's what he calls it he's got the
he's got it a little mixed up but that's
all right take a look at the gallup poll
and there were others too they got
horrible marks
and that disease is a much lesser
problem
and of course we've already fact checked
this during
swine flu the obama biden administration
had 66 percent
approval in a polarized political
environment
like the one that we have 66 approval
getting 66 of the country to agree on on
anything
is an accomplishment in and of itself so
trump also wrong
on the facts and making people look
physically ill
from these rants and then trump flew out
to arizona and it got even worse and i'm
going to talk about that next
so after his event with women where he
made
the big announcement that he's pardoning
susan b
anthony who's been dead for almost 120
years
trump did another event in yuma arizona
and
this was really a house of horrors
donald trump came out of his plane
and his first statement was right away
that because he caught sleepy joe spying
on him
which is treason he should get another
four years
on top of the four years he's seeking
now take a look at this
thank you very much
and you know considering that we caught
president obama
and sleepy joe biden spying on our
campaign treason
will probably be entitled to another
four more years after that
now i know when trump does this a lot of
people say david this doesn't even
deserve attention
because he won't get a third term of
course he won't
of course he won't but what deserves
attention
is that his followers buy into this
stuff they are so
easily convinced that hey yeah it was
unfair
trump should get a third term because of
obama and biden despite it all being
made up and it
all being ridiculous and this one got
bad very very quickly
this next clip might be the top
instance of projection that i've seen
from donald trump
saying the biden campaign is cult-like
if you can imagine that we're talking
about abolishing prisons
biden's campaign has turned into a cult
for open border and other zealots
by the way they want to double and
triple your taxes
trump wondered aloud about injecting
bleach
and alcohol to treat coronavirus and
many of his followers stood behind him
saying you know maybe it's not such a
bad idea
and trump says the biden campaign is
like a cult
yeah the biden campaign has fallen for
the cult
of prioritizing democracy and competence
in the oval office that's the biden cult
that we have
there's actually a lot that's
interesting here and so
first there's the projection which with
trump is huge he often accuses
others of that which he himself is
guilty of or
he accuses the followers of biden
of that which his followers actually are
guilty of but also
the cult-like nature of trump's
followers
is a topic of academic inquiry it's not
just oh
trump says biden followers or cultists
but
trump's own followers are really the
cultists this has been studied
academically we interviewed cult expert
stephen hassan
about cults and how the trump
uh i don't i'm looking for a word other
than cult to say it's like a cult
the the base of trump is very
cult-like so the projection is
particularly acute here
and then donald trump suggests that were
it not for him
we might not have the second amendment
right now the second amendment
would be gone if trump weren't president
and she's running against a gentleman
who is uh
when you read what he's done when you
read what he said about
the second amendment and about all other
things you're not going to want to vote
for
you're not going to want to have them
play with your second amendment
i'll tell you what if i weren't
president i don't believe doug you'd
have a second amendment right now i
don't think you'd
the pressure that was put on this is
also
another one of these uh features or bugs
depending on how you look at it of
donald trump's personality issues
this is a delusion of grandeur right the
second amendment of the constitution has
been around since 1791 it's been 229
years
it has nothing to do with donald trump
it remaining doesn't require donald
trump
to get rid of it you would need a new
amendment and that just would not happen
there's just a
the the second amendment is completely
safe and trump has nothing to do with it
being safe
and then right in the middle of a
xenophobic
racist rant about murderers and killers
trump short circuits right in the middle
of the word removals that thing
happened where he glitches on a word and
his right shoulder spasms you have to
watch it
uh to understand it let's take a quick
look in facilities
this would make removing illegal aliens
totally impossible
and you would have murderers killers
rapists in your midst i don't think so
immediately suspend all removals
triggering a tidal wave of
really a flood if you think a flood so
anyway every day
trump doing some kind of event like this
clearly not liking the dnc
and the attention that joe biden is
getting and each event is worse
than the previous more embarrassing and
the really embarrassing thing
on top of trump uh it's
doing these events is that no matter
what trump says
there's always a crowd that will cheer
for it it doesn't matter how absurd
how ridiculous how unconstitutional
trump can always get a group of
supporters together he can find a group
no matter what that will cheer for
anything he says and that's the really
scary part
because when we step back and we say
what has happened to the country over
the last three and a half years
what is the future of the country trump
is one person
when you find 63 million people to vote
for it
that's the real indictment of the
country and as i said before
if trump wins he'll probably win with
around 65 or 66 million votes
if trump loses in november
he will lose with likely between 60 and
65 million votes
and even if he is not the president
starting on january 20th
those 60 plus million people who are
going to vote for him
they still will live here they will
still be a problem that we have to
contend with and
i won't redo that analysis because i i
did it recently enough
okay we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p
a very good question here from someone
thinking ahead
about voting in november take a listen
hey david uh joe from california yeah um
hey i've been seen online
uh people are suggesting uh that they
take their mailing ballot their absentee
ballot
to the polling place and dropping it off
right therefore not having to
uh put it on the post office to have to
mail it and send it in yep what do you
think good idea i think so
like to know your thoughts yeah so so
listen um the answer is
it's probably a good idea to go and drop
off your ballot if you're able to but
what you have to understand is the post
office is a public service
and there's a lot of people in this
country who don't have vehicles
and can't easily get to uh city hall
or wherever you can drop off your ballot
there are people who
live in really rural areas so even if
they have a car they'd have to take half
a day off from work to go and drop off
their ballot
etc etc so it really shouldn't depend on
people going and dropping off their
ballot at city hall in person
i plan to do it because boston is small
and i can do it right i'll just find
uh 20 minutes and i'll go over and and i
will drop it off
depending on where you live you may be
better off just
mailing the ballot early so yes it is a
good idea to go and drop off the ballot
in person
depending on your circumstances where
you have to drop it off
how much you trust the the mail system
where you are and how early you're able
to send your ballot but certainly
something people should consider
on today's bonus show we will talk about
north korean literature leader kim
jong-un
reportedly condemning pet ownership as
decadence
and ordering dogs to be confiscated
we're going to talk about the texas
governor proposing freezing property tax
revenue
if a city defunds police and we will
talk about
businesses that are saying you know even
if trump does this payroll tax thing
we're just not going to do it we're not
going to participate
so a lot of important meaty stories
on today's bonus show and remember that
august 23rd
that's coming up august 23rd is the 15th
anniversary of the david pakman show
we will be having a single day
membership special
which you can be notified about by
signing up
for our newsletter at davidpakman.com
i'll see you on the bonus
show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you read or
listen to an entire non-fiction book in
just fifteen minutes you can try
blinkist for free
and save twenty five percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist dot com slash
david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video